اه طبعا انا بحيي حضرتك عليه جدا اه
الوصفه صحيح ودقيق جدا هو التطرف مبدا
التطرف التطرف لا قضيه ما او التطرف لمنهج
ما او التطرف ما مش دايما الملتفين حوالين
الهدف او المتطرفين بيكونوا مؤمنين بالهدف
او هم يسعون لتحقيق الهدف او الفكره او
القضيه غالبا اسباب انضمام الاشخاص
التنظيمات الارهابيه او التنظيمات
المتطرفه بتبقى مختلفه على حسب اسباب
شخصيه فروق الفرديه هنا شغاله بشكل فاعل
جدا يعني حتى لما احنا بنتكلم نقول ايه
لماذا ينضم الشباب للتنظيمات الارهابيه
الحقيقه ان هو لا يوجد سبب شامل الجامع
مانع نقدر نقول ان هو السبب اللي بيخلي كل
الشباب ينضم والتظلمات الارهابيه في فروق
فرديه ما بينهم وبين بعض منها في الدول
الاوروبيه والدول المتقدمه
وجود فراغ فراغ عند الشباب بيحاولوا يملك
قضايا او قناعات يتمنوها بشكل
يصل الى حد الايمان واليقين لان ما فيش
ايمان ويقيم بديل لما ما يكونش في ايمان
ويقين بديل بتبحث انت على قناعه تتبناها
يعني مثلا اللي
شوهه اللوحه بتاعت الفنان فانجو هل نقدر
نعتبرهم ان هم مدافعين وعين عن البيئه انا
عايزه اقول لحضرتك حاجه يعني هم مثلا في
الرساله بتاعتهم اللي هم بيبعثوها بيقولوا
ان هم عايزين العالم يتوقف بشكل فوري عن
استخدام الفحم واستخدام ال همم
الاحفوري هل في حاجه اسمها
البترول هل في حاجه اسمها يتوقف بشكل فوري
طبعا بيبقى فيه اهداف غير منطقيه وغير
قابله للتطبيق الاني والحالي فهم زي ما
بيقولوا كده بيبتزوا الانظمه على ان هي من
الحاجات ليس بمقدورها ان هي تعملها في
الوقت الراهب وبيضغطوا عليها بالشكل ده
المقتنعين او المؤمنين بقضيه بشكل واعي
وبشكل رزنا ولعائل عمرهم ما يتصرفوا
تصرفات اللي زي دي بالنسبه لفكره الارهاب
والتصنيفات بتاعه الارهاب على حسب منظمه
الاقتصاد والسلام اللي هي بتصدر مؤشر
الارهاب العالمي لكلنا بنستناه هي مصنفه
الارهاب لثلاث انماط ارهاب سياسي وارهاب
ديني وارهاب انفصالي
في اخر تقرير لها قالت ان همم
النشطاء البيئيين المتطرفين اكثر قابليه
لتكوين انشطه ارهابيه ممكن تمكن المنظمه
بعد كده ان هي تدرج النمط ده في الارهاب
من الارهاب في المؤشر السنه بتاعها يبقى
نمط بيقاس بشكل همم بشكل دوري وبشكل سنوي
فبالتالي احنا قدام باترن نمط
ظهر وهيتصاعد الفتره اللي جايه عايزه اقول
لحضرتك ان في جهود كثيره جدا العالم كله
اعترف بازمه التغيرات المناخيه وبيبذل
جهود كبيره جدا عشان يواجهها وده قلل
الفتره اللي فاتت من حده التطرف ده ولكن
الفتره اللي جايه مع الاضطرابات اللي
بتحصل حوالين العالم الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اضطرار دول زي دول اوروبا اللي
هي ترجع مره ثانيه تعتمد على الفحم عمل
موجه عنف مضاده وموجه التطرف مضاده ضد
الحكومات اللي هي بتلجا للبدائل قلقانيه
مش البدائل الدائمه يعني مثلا في المانيا
حرك التطرف زاد والعنف زاد نتيجه لتصريحات
الحكومه الالمانيه هي هترجع بشكل مؤقتا
ليه
الفحم
بديل الى ان تنتهي الازمه